the United Nations Security Council is
holding an emergency meeting this
morning on Syria following the recent
suspected chemical weapons attack Russia
requested the meeting and said that top
priority should be to avert a wider war
this morning russia's Foreign Minister
claimed the attack was staged with the
help of a foreign secret service
president Trump discussed US military
options on Syria with his advisors and
American allies yesterday but has not
made a final decision David Martin is at
the Pentagon David good morning good
morning president Trump spoke with the
British prime minister last night and
the two leaders agreed that Syria's
President Assad has a history of using
chemical weapons and that something has
to be done to stop him from doing it
again I believe there was a chemical
attack and we're looking for the actual
evidence the pictures of the aftermath
of last weekend's suspected chemical
attack in Syria that killed 42 and
injured over 500 are compelling but two
critical questions remain what kind of
chemical and who was responsible CBS
News analyst Mike Morell if the
president is going to take military
action the intelligence community would
want to give him a high confidence
judgment intelligence analysts have
concluded the symptoms shown in the
videos are consistent with exposure to
chlorine gas and that some of the
victims look like they had been exposed
to a nerve agent but that's not enough
you can only really nail it down when
you get a blood sample that you have
confidence in where that blood sample
came from and what the chain of custody
was US officials say blood samples
provided by hospital workers do indeed
confirm the presence of chemicals but
they need to be sure the evidence hasn't
been doctored Assad's never been
stronger than he is today so the
opposition would want nothing more right
now than to then to significantly weaken
him with a US air strike over the past
six months US intelligence has confirmed
four other chemical attacks carried out
by the regime but none of them triggered
a military response the stakes are
higher this time because Russia has
warned the u.s. not to strike I do think
there's a possibility here of a military
confrontation between the United States
and
Russia in Syria an international team of
chemical weapons inspectors is scheduled
to arrive at the scene of the attack
tomorrow they could find soil samples
that prove what kind of chemicals were
used but that still would not answer the
question of who is responsible
gaile all right David Martin reporting
from Washington thank you